- Ça faisait longtemps que des
files de touristes aussi longues
n'avaient pas été aperçues à
Saint-Jean.
Ces Québécois, eux, ont
conduit jusqu'ici.
- Ça fait deux ans que
ma conjointe voulait faire
Terre-Neuve, puis qu'on
le remettait. Puis C'est à
cette année que ça se passait.
- Ça fait changement de Laval
quand même.
- (la femme): Oh, mon Dieu, oui.
- (l'homme): Énorm O O O Oui.
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est pourtant une autre
clientèle touristique que
la province a dans sa mire :
les Terre-Neuviens, maintenant
établis ailleurs.
STEVE CROCKER, ministre Tourisme
Terre-Neuve-et-Labrador
"Nous savions que c'es
un marché qui a évidemment été
perturbé au cours des dernières
années, dit le ministre du
Tourisme."
(anglais)
C'est donc pour les convaincre
de revenir, mais aussi pour
attirer de nouveaux visiteurs,
que la campagne "Come Home
2022" a été lancée.
Une invitation à rentrer à
la maison qu'on aperçoit un peu
partout : dans les rues, à
l'aéroport et sur les plaques
d'immatriculation des voitures.
Pour ces propriétaires de gîte,
toute initiative pour stimuler
le tourisme est bienvenue, après
deux années particulièrement
éprouvantes.
Le portrait est semblable
ailleurs. Ce musée n'a accueilli
qu'environ 20 000 visiteurs
peleleleles premiers mois de
la pandémie; c'est 100 000 de
moins que l'année précédente.
Mais avec la levée des mesures
sanitaires, le tourisme reprend
clairement de la vigueur à
Saint-Jean.
Ce restaurant, une institution
locale, vient par exemple de
vi m m m meilleur mois d'avril
de son existence.
- So this is Mallard Cottage
proper. It's about 250 yearsd.d.
- N'empêche, son chef doute de
la pertinence de la campagne
e e e e Home 2022", qui a coûté
4 millions $ aux contribuables.
Selon lui, le gouvernement
devrait plutôt s'attaquer aux
obstacles que rencontrent
les touristes, comme
le prix des billets d'avion
ou la pénurie de voitures de
location.
Cette représentante de
l'industrie touristique croit,
quant à elle, que la campagne de
promotion était nécessaire dans
un marché où la compétition est
féroce.
MICHELLE LEBLANC, propriétaire,
restaurant Chinched
- Ça a déjà commencé. Ça,c'c'c'.
- Dans cet autre restaurant,
on sent aussi que les touristes
répondent déjà présents. Ce sont
plutôt les employés qui manquent
à l'appel.
- Normalement, on a fait comme
des piles, des piles de
personnes qui veulent
aiaiaiailler, mais maintenant,
il faut chercher beaucoup pour.
- Sous des airs de retour à
la normale qui font le bonheur
des visiteurs,
... l'industrie n'a pas fini de
faire face aux défis.
Ici Mathieu papillon,
Radio-Canada,